where does the story begin for you like
how do you know the beginning of one
when you start writing or even you're
reading someone else's material for me
the beginning of a story is where you're
introduced to a character and you can
empathize with them I think it that's
the point where the story really begins
because until you can step into the
shoes of whoever your protagonist is
your story can't really start everything
up into that point is things that you
didn't necessarily need and once that
moment happens and it clicks into place
that's when you're like okay now as an
audience member
the story begins and I'm following this
character's journey whoever they are and
seeing where it leads me you think of a
few characters where you were able to
empathize with them maybe they even
weren't someone that if you saw them in
real life you would really empathize but
once you see that for from that you know
sort of directors perspective well I
think one of the best examples and I
think why this was such a successful
show Breaking Bad was Walter White's
character and I remember talking about
you know reading the script of something
before you actually watch it I remember
reading the pilot for that and it
happens so quickly in that where you
step into Walter White's shoes as a
character you see the life he's leading
he's a teacher he's got to deal with
these students and then he goes home and
he has sort of like this contentious
relationship with his wife and he finds
out he has cancer and it's like you're
like whoa this guy is dealing with a lot
of issues and you can relate to him
right because who has it in their life
you know woken up one morning and feel
like they're living like the worst
possible version of their life and
there's all these things that are
happening to them and it's it's you just
relate to that right so as soon as that
happens in that story
you're already empathizing with Walter
and when he gets the opportunity to kind
of break bad as they kind of they said
you're there with him right you want to
see how far you can take this
what's gonna happen to him and I think
that's the key to interesting stories is
getting you to empathize with you know
who your hero is so that when things go
bad or when they're making sometimes
really bad choices you're not yelling at
the screen you're just saying that he
had no other like or she had no other
choice to make I was just like they're
putting these circumstances and you're
able to step into their shoes and see
from that perspective and it's
interesting to have his character plays
off the Jesse character right because
Jesse's situation isn't as dire and he's
much more flipping and cavalier about
things where it was the stakes for
Walter are much higher he's got a son
that has a disability and yeah and and
you know you see these boys come in the
store or whatever and in that scene
right there you really feel you know the
clothing store wherever that they are
and and the if you were to see that
normally you think well this person is
not a good person but then undo in the
context of why that happened it makes
sense so just to see his character in
these dire straits and then played off
the Jesse character who's you know yeah
it's just flipping about yeah yeah and I
think but I think that's the reason why
Walter is the protagonist that shows
right that's the audience perspective
into this world is that character and
you can empathize with him and see where
he's coming from
you